estoy seguro que en este punto de la
lista de vídeos de biología seguramente
estás pensando una pregunta muy natural
cómo se determina el género el género de
un organismo y bueno la respuesta no es
tan obvia porque a lo largo del reino
animal se determina de diferentes
maneras por ejemplo los reptiles no
todos los reptiles pero en algunas
especies si los reptiles en los reptiles
el ambiente determina el sexo así que
déjame ponerlo aquí
ambiente puede ser la temperatura la que
determinan si el embrión se desarrollará
como un macho o como una hembra incluso
pueden ser otros factores ambientales en
otros animales especialmente en los
mamíferos y recuerda que nosotros somos
un ejemplo es la base genética así que
déjame ponerlo aquí los mamíferos bueno
es nuestra base genética
may
y seguramente estás pensando que una
respuesta para esta pregunta sería decir
hey hay diferentes alelos un alelo
femenino o uno masculino
oa lo mejor estás pensando en esta otra
posibilidad que hay muchas otras
características que diferencian a un
hombre de una mujer y justo esta segunda
idea es la correcta debe de haber un
gran conjunto de genes que trabajan
juntos para poder hacer esto es más no
sólo un conjunto de genes
de hecho cromosomas completos lo
determinan así que déjame dibujar por
aquí un núcleo imaginarte que este es un
núcleo iba a ser el núcleo de un hombre
entonces 22 pares de los cromosomas son
cromosomas que no determinan el sexo los
voy a dibujar aquí tengo uno este es mi
primer par homólogo 4 8 10
14 y no puedo seguir y seguir y seguir
hasta que eventualmente tendrás 22 pares
estos 22 pares estos de aquí tienen el
nombre de autosómicos déjame ponerlo así
a tu show
autosómicos y estos son sólo parece
estándar de cromosomas que codifican
para distintas cosas cada uno de estos
es un par homólogo como aprendimos antes
así que déjame ponerlo este
un par homólogo homólogo que como
aprendimos antes un cromosoma lo
obtienes de cada padre no necesariamente
cada uno de ellos codifica para lo mismo
pero codifican para los mismos genes es
decir que si el gen de color de los ojos
está en este cromosoma bueno entonces
también deba estar en su cromosoma
homólogo en este también va a estar
aunque tengas diferentes versiones para
el color de ojos en cada uno estos van a
determinar su fenotipo y bueno estos son
genes estándar que no tienen que ver con
nuestro sexo pero también tenemos estos
dos cromosomas especiales que le voy a
poner aquí uno de ellos lo voy a poner
con este color muy grande y largo
mientras que voy a tomar este color azul
para hacer otro de ellos otro cromosoma
el cual será azul y corto y lo primero
que puedes notar es que no se ven
homólogos como pueden codificar para lo
mismo cuando uno es azul y corto y el
otro es café y largo y eso es verdad
ellos no son homólogos a estos los
llamamos cromosomas sexuales así que
déjame ponerlo
estos van a ser mis cromosomas sexuales
cromosomas sexuales el cromosoma largo
de aquí este de color café es al que por
convención se le llama cromosoma x así
que déjame ponerlo este de aquí es mi
cromosoma x x déjame por el racing
mientras que el pequeño y azul va a ser
mi cromosoma y así que voy a buscar el
color y este lo voy a poner así creo
son más
y para saber si el mamífero es un macho
o una hembra el sistema es muy simple si
tú tienes un cromosoma jane entonces
eres varón ahora bien este núcleo que
acabo de dibujar y obviamente puedes
imaginar que el citoplasma lo está
rodeando es el núcleo de un hombre si tú
tienes un cromosoma x y ahorita te diré
por qué sólo lo puedes obtener de tu
mamá pero déjame ponerlo aquí si tú
tienes a un cromosoma x y tienes un
cromosoma yo como en este núcleo quién
es además un cromosoma y este lo tienes
de tu mamá y este lo tienes de tu papá
entonces eres un nombre pero de forma
más general
voy a poner macho ahora bien también
puedes obtener un cromosoma x de tu mamá
incluso a saba x de tu papá entonces
serás mujer pero de forma más general
voy a poner hembra
de hecho podríamos dibujar un cuadro en
el cual sería un cuadro bastante
sencillo pero nos mostrará las
posibilidades si existen no sé digamos
que este es el genotipo de la madre x x
recuerda que tenemos dos cromosomas x y
justo esto es lo que la hace ser la
madre y no el padre y éste es el
genotipo del padre un cromosoma x y un
cromosoma bien y un cromosoma ahora bien
cuáles son las posibles combinaciones de
su descendencia
bueno pues veámoslo así la madre puede
dar este cromosoma x y el padre este
cromosoma x lo cual obtendríamos un x x
y en este caso nos dará una hembra si la
madre de este cromosoma x y el padre de
este cromosoma x obtendrías otro x x lo
cual es también una hembra y bueno si te
das cuenta tu mamá siempre va a dar un
cromosoma x un cromosoma x un cromosoma
x pero estos dos de abajo van a ser
machos
esto va a tener cromosoma x james y esto
también xy por lo tanto en este caso en
el cual la madre donde un cromosoma x y
el padre donde un cromosoma gem vamos a
obtener dos machos y te das cuenta estas
de aquí serán hembras estos aquí serán
machos y funcionan bien porque la mitad
son hembras y la mitad son machos pero
un hecho interesante y de hecho algo
irónico que seguramente te va a llamar
la atención va a ser lo siguiente quien
determina si la cría será macho o hembra
es la madre o el padre bueno si te das
cuenta la madre siempre dará el
cromosoma x debido al contenido genético
a floyd en sus óvulos el gameto femenino
por lo tanto no puede determinar el sexo
de los hijos todo está determinado por
el padre así que déjame dibujarlo de
esta manera si el padre produce gran
número de espermatozoides así que déjame
dibujar uno por aquí aquí tengo a uno de
ellos por acá puedo tener a otro de
ellos
se me ocurre poner a otro de ellos o tal
vez por acá al otro de ellos y bueno
algunos de estos espermatozoides van a
tener como cromosoma x esto imagina que
también tiene como cromosoma x y bueno
también otros van a tener como cromosoma
bien éste también como cromosoma y ahora
bien si esta chica ganas la carrera ella
gana la carrera y entonces fecunda
lóbulo observa que vamos a obtener una
hembra mientras que si este
espermatozoide gana la carrera dará
lugar a un macho y dije que esto es
irónico ya que a lo largo de la historia
y para eso deja de subir un poco la
pantalla a lo largo de la historia ha
habido casos interesantes por ejemplo
creo que el más famoso es el siguiente
enrique octavo
estaba obsesionado por tener un mi hijo
varón que llevará el apellido de la
familia y seguramente esto es escuchado
por qué pasa con bastantes hombres en
general nuestras civilizaciones han
estado dominadas por hombres y muchos de
ellos se obsesionan con la idea de tener
un hijo varón y bueno en el caso de
enrique octavo lo que buscaba era
alguien que se hiciera cargo de su país
estos hombres tienden a desilusionarse y
culpar a sus esposas de tener solamente
hijas pero todo es culpa de los hombres
enrique octavo y su caso más famoso fue
con ana bolena no soy experto en
historia pero su caso es bastante sabido
él se molestó con ella porque no le daba
un hijo varón y busco una razón para que
la decapitaron a pesar de que todo esto
era su culpa
su culpa culpa y seguramente él producía
muchos más espermatozoides que se veían
como éste o como éste que
espermatozoides que si hubieran como
éste
en fin eventualmente tuvo un hijo varón
heredero y si suponemos que fue su hijo
bueno seguramente produjo algunos de
estos y es también pero la mayor parte
de la culpa era de enrique octavo y fue
por eso que dije que era bastante
irónico muchas veces las personas que
culpan son las culpables de la falta de
un hijo varón ahora bien una pregunta
que puede surgir de inmediatamente sería
hayes al todo este cromosoma está
relacionado sólo con nuestras
características sexuales o hay otras
cosas en ellos y para explicarte eso
imagínate que estos son los cromosomas
este de aquí es mi cromosoma x y por
aquí voy a hacer al micrófono soma ya
esté aquí va a ser mi cromosoma jr este
cromosoma x es famoso por tener el menor
número de genes este de aquí tiene
aproximadamente en alrededor
1500 genes
es decir codifica para muchas cosas
mientras que este de aquí este pequeño
cromosoma ya tienen aproximadamente 78
genes 78 genes muy pocos y en su mayoría
estos genes sirven para determinar el
sexo y bueno la manera que lo hacen es
por medio de un gen llamado el gen srf
el gen srf supongamos que están aquí es
el gen que participa en el desarrollo de
los testículos déjame escribir la srm es
los testículos
es decir las gónadas masculinas entonces
este gen empezará a codificar para cosas
que eventualmente llevarán al desarrollo
de los testículos y si no lo tienes
bueno eso no pasará y se desarrollará
una hembra es decir que existen también
genes que codifican para otras
características por ejemplo los casos
más famosos son los relacionados con
algunas enfermedades específicas
ahora para darte unos ejemplos déjenme
bajar un poco la pantalla y vamos a
hablar acerca de algunos ejemplos en
mutaciones así que voy a poner aquí
mutaciones y bueno vamos a hablar por
ejemplo de la mutación que causa el
daltonismo daltonismo la cual es una
mutación que causa una ceguera al color
verde y puede mantener podemos hablar
acerca de la hemofilia
no voy a poner con este color
la cual es una enfermedad donde la
sangre no coagula adecuadamente de hecho
existen varios tipos de hemofilia pero
vamos a hablar de ese tipo de hemofilia
estos dos ejemplos son mutaciones en el
cromosoma x y son mutaciones recesivas
déjame ponerlo así mutación
en el cromosoma xy recesiva
si va
y esto qué significa significa que ambos
cromosomas x en el caso de la hemofilia
deben de tener la mutación de la
hemofilia para que expreses el fenotipo
de tener hemofilia por ejemplo si
tenemos a una mujer que tiene un
cromosoma x normal y otro cromosoma x y
lo voy a poner con este super índice h
de hemofilia bueno como este no obtiene
ambos cromosomas x con el caso de la
hemofilia entonces tendremos que ella
sólo será una portadora su fenotipo será
no expresar la hemofilia déjame ponerlo
ella
no tendrá hemofilia
filia en cambio si tenemos a otra
persona a otra mujer que tiene el par de
cromosomas x y los dos cromosomas
expresan el súper índice h h h esto
quiere decir que los dos cromosomas
tienen la mutación recesiva y eso quiere
decir que esta mujer si va a expresar en
su fenotipo hemofilia ahora los hombres
sólo tienen un cromosoma x de acuerdo
entonces para qué un hombre presente
hemofilia es suficiente con que tenga un
cromosoma x que tenga esta mutación así
que déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla
para hablar de esto si tengo a un hombre
que tiene aquí su cromosoma x y éste
tiene hemofilia y vamos a pensar que por
acá está su cromosoma y bueno pues este
individuo va a presentar hemofilia este
individuo va a presentar hemofilia ya
que tiene un cromosoma con la mutación
seguramente debes de tener ahora una
pregunta que debe estar surgiendo ya que
esta es una mutación poco frecuente la
pregunta es quién tiene mayor
probabilidad de tener hemofilia un
hombre o una mujer bueno si es un alelo
con baja frecuencia y para que una mujer
lo exprese debe tener dos copias de él
bueno vamos a ver pues la frecuencia y
busque antes de hacer este vídeo en que
la frecuencia para los hombres dice que
uno de cada cinco mil a diez mil hombres
tienen hemofilia así que digamos que la
frecuencia al el icam de tener hemofilia
es uno entre 7000 entre 7000 y bueno
esta es la frecuencia de alicante que me
ponerlo la frecuencia de tener un
cromosoma x h un cromosoma x h ahora
bien esta frecuencia significa que
existe una probabilidad de 1 entre 7000
de que el cromosoma x que obtuvieron
tenga esta versión con hemofilia no
importa el cromosoma jr porque
esencialmente no cuantifica en la
coagulación de la sangre
para otras cosas que llevan a tener
hemofilia ahora para que una mujer
tengamos william que tiene que pasar
observa que ella debe de tener dos
cromosomas x con esta mutación y bueno
la probabilidad de que cada uno tenga
esta mutación es de 1 entre 7000
entonces que me quedaría este de aquí
tendrá una probabilidad de 1 entre 7000
entre 7.000 y este de aquí pues tiene la
misma probabilidad 1 entre 7000 entre
7000 entonces la probabilidad de que una
mujer tenga hemofilia es 1 entre 7000
por 1 entre 7000 lo cual me va a dar a 1
entre 49 micrones 49 millones como
puedes imaginar la incidencia de mozilla
en mujeres es mucho menor que la
incidencia de hemofilia en hombres y en
general para cualquier característica
ligada al sexo si es recesiva
es decir significa que un hombre que la
tenga la expresará porque no tiene otro
cromosoma x que lo dominen y para que
una mujer lo presente debe tener ambos
cromosomas con la mutación entonces si
hablamos de esta característica y
pensamos en la incidencia en hombres y
la incidencia en mujeres
y para eso déjame bajar un poco más esta
pantalla así que si digo que h déjame
ponerlo con este color h es la
incidencia en los hombres
déjame ponerlo así
sí
desea
hombres hombres y voy a poner m m como
la incidencia en las mujeres
bueno pues date cuenta de lo siguiente
recuerda que a éste lo puedes ver como
la frecuencia alérgica de que esta
mutación esté en el cromosoma x como lo
vimos aquí por lo que las mujeres deben
tener dos copias de éste para expresar
esta mutación entonces la frecuencia
delicada de las mujeres es bueno pues h
h elevado al cuadrado no es así y puedes
decir hey este número se ve muy grande
lo estoy elevando al cuadrado pero
tienes que recordar que esta frecuencia
siempre va a ser menor que 1 h siempre
va a ser el menor que 1 por lo tanto
este número empieza a aparecer más
pequeño en este caso la frecuencia
alélica de poseer la hemofilia era 1
entre 7000 aquí teníamos uno entre 7000
7.000 y es por eso que cuando el leve al
cuadrado uno entre 7000 resultó que m
pues la incidencia de las mujeres era de
49 millones
millones de cualquier manera espero que
todo esto lo hayas encontrado bastante
interesante y ahora ya sabes que hizo
que fuéramos hombres y mujeres y mejor
aún a quién culpar cuando los padres
quieren tener hijos varones y no pueden